intentions de vote pour les européennes
selon un sondage ifop
on voit s'afficher qui est publié
aujourd'hui dans le quotidien l'opinion
alors on le voit le rassemblement
national totalise 24 % des intentions de
vote +2 % par rapport au mois dernier
alors que tous les autres partis à
l'exception de debout la france sont en
également progression et europe ecologie
les verts vous avez raison de le
souligner est tout à fait lucide alors
la question linguistique justement
est-ce que ça tombe sur vous les gilets
jaunes ont réussi à faire oublier le
débat de l'entre-deux-tours de marine le
pen jean nazis doublons temps on a dit
ici je pense que c'est aussi marine le
pen qui a réussi à le faire oublier
parce que je pense qu'elle est parmi les
leaders politiques français
celle qui a parlé et je regrette de le
dire souvent avec le plus d'empathie de
ce qui s'était passé et qu'elle a trouvé
des mots à la galerie le je pense
qu'elle a bien compris les choses est là
on voit que le métier politique et
existe chez elle et je pense qu'à
l'avenir du métier je pense qu'ils ont
moins de métier qu'elle est que
peut-être quand on est au front national
ces questions là aussi sont des
questions sur lesquelles il ya un vrai
programme et il ya un vrai contact avec
les électeurs je trouve qu'on a senti
que de ce côté là elle avait quelque
chose qui remontait du terrain qui était
plus authentique que les autres donc ça
me semble assez d'ailleurs je vois que
debout la france a aussi pas mal gagné
dont je vais nicolas dupont aignan est
quand même quelqu'un qui avait fait
alliance avec marine le pen au moment de
la présidentielle donc ça fait quelque
chose d'énorme c'est cohérent dans là
c'est très cohérent mais ça veut dire
que ça fait 8 + 24 a fait prendre 2 donc
je trouve que c'est très c'est très
cohérent et très effrayant
et je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
vraiment sur le langage qui est tenue
l'empathie la capacité on en parle tout
de suite mais comme pour compléter ce
que dit lucie l'on va effectivement à
écouter marine le pen elle était hier
sur france 2 et elle dit effectivement
que c'est une majorité silencieuse qui
s'expriment et que macro lui emmanuel
macron n'a pas compris cette crise il
n'a pas analysé en réalité les ressorts
de cette crise de cette souffrance des
français qui n'est pas exclusivement
liée au pouvoir d'achat qui est une
contestation du modèle de la
mondialisation sauvage de la
dérégulation de la concurrence
internationale déloyale de la captation
des richesses par des grands groupes au
détriment des tpe pme qui est cette
politique exclusivement des à
destination des minorités et que cette
majorité silencieuse elle vient dire
coucou en exil
alexis poulain d'accord avec lucile ou
pas elle avait vu
et elle a mieux compris et su trouver
les mots passe au gilet jaune d'opel
oui elle a clairement compris ce qui se
passait depuis longtemps mais c'est
aussi parce que débute ce mouvement
était un mouvement anti fiscale sur la
taxe écologistes ont dia que l'écologie
c'est pas non plus un point fort du
front national par contre la politique
anti fiscal oui il y avait donc de l'éco
direct et puis parce qu'aussi c'est un
parti le front national qui connaît
davantage la france des régions qui a
des élus qui aussi connaît ça là où
emmanuel macron arrive avec une vision
de la france complètement biaisé une
france qui connaît pas la france des
invisibles qui s'est montrée avec ses
gilet jaune et c'est vrai qu'il a très
mal analysé cette crise pensant que elle
passerait vite que il fallait garder le
cap enfin trois semaines quatre semaines
d'émeutes pour finalement dira peut-être
que le cap va être un peu changé on le
voit là un peu comme un un responsable
de start up qui fait un pivot on appelle
ça dans le monde de la start-up cercle
produits marchent pas sur un marché
alors aux basques lorientais continuer à
essayer de vendre le produit
or je pense pas que son discours est
changé grand chose sur la mobilisation
du gilet jaune
c'est quelque chose de d'une rupture
consommée de cet ordre là et le fait que
le front national engrange des voix sur
ce thème là c'est normal il ya un autre
fait c'est que il ya les européennes qui
arrivait que ça a toujours été des
élections fare de ce parti et une fois
n'est pas coutume ça va encore être une
fois une un grand moment politique pour
le front national puisqu'ils vivent de
ces thèmes-là anti europe et se
structure autour de sa marque pour
rebondir sur ce que dit alexis anyama
croix a su trouver les mots pas lundi
soir on voit visiblement oui et non aux
certains ont décidé de sortir des ronds
points parce que c'était trop compliqué
qu'il apporte une un début de réponse
notamment en matière de pouvoir d'achat
c'est pas c'est pas petit le geste qu'il
a consenti que le que l'exécutif consent
sûre en terme de deux milliards d'euros
macroéconomique mans je veux dire c'est
quand même à faire un effort cumulé avec
ce qui s'est fait
dès fin 2010 8 de près de 20 milliards
d'euros ce qui n'était pas prévu au
départ donc c'est pas rien donc ça peut
toucher des gens qui se disent bon bah
c'est bon on a obtenu ce qu'on a voulu
par contre ça ne va pas changer de faire
changer d'avis les plus radicaux ceux
qui veulent la suppression du sénat là
une démocratie participative citoyenne
avec des référendums locaux tout le
temps vire c'est ça dépend ce contre
quoi se battre les gens qui manifestent
donc oui ça y est en effet et non ça n'a
pas eu d'effet et d'un autre côté moi ça
me surprend pas que marine le pen ou
même la france ont soumis ce tir leurs
marrons du feu avec cette crise mais
parce qu'il attire moins qu'on aurait
peut-être pu le relancer
oui mais d'un autre côté c'est ce sont
les deux parties sur les partis qui sont
les partis populaires aujourd'hui les
classes populaires elles votent plus au
ps qui a disparu elle voit le plus bas
la france a soumis non parce que je
pense que la france réduise en a fait
beaucoup plus que le front national
le fin le rn a été menée avec les plus
plus light plus light pu maîtriser a
laissé faire c'est très bien marine le
pen qu'il suffit de laisser faire pour
engranger l'eau qu'il est fou donkey la
moelle à la république c'est moi et il a
fallu qu'ils paradent alekseev l'habitat
pact a relaté il ya eu rufin
effectivement qui a fait quelques ronds
points mais le mouvement de la france a
soumises a été très en retrait également
présent mais évidemment les gilet jaune
justement c'est un mouvement intéressant
parce qu' ils ont fait extrêmement
attention à l'entrisme politique on a vu
des porte paroles qui sont faits dégagée
par ce qu'ils venaient de debout la
france par exemple on voit vraiment un
doute 1
quelque chose de l'ordre du web de
suspicion suspicion donc du politique en
disant on ne veut pas être récupérés
donc c'est tout le monde marche sur des
oeufs sur ce mouvement personne peut
tirer ses marrons du feu
moi je pense que le mouvement marche
pour le front national parce que
globalement le mouvement nationaliste
fonctionne très bien en europe elle
était avec steve banane encore samedi à
bruxelles où là il se gargarisait sur le
fait que le président d'un côté paris
était en flammes et l'italie étaient
déjà aux mains de la ligue
voilà c'est un mouvement global
aujourd'hui où les populistes
nationalistes ont le vent en poupe
donc les gilet jaune ou pas le front
national de toute façon parce que
l'échéance européenne arrive est sur une
pente ascendante
karine c'est une analyse très politique
politicienne
je sais pas si c'est cette crise qui est
une aubaine pour le front national
s'était plutôt l'abandon par les partis
de gouvernement des préoccupations de
toute cette classe là qui est une
aubaine pour le front national et celle
là cest tags ont dans là ça fait très
longtemps qu'il dure il a d'ailleurs été
très bien analysé par christophe guilluy
qu'il a théorisé dans plusieurs livres
et je suis très étonné très surprise que
cette ce sondage arrive comme une
surprise que cette crise avait comme une
surprise quand on voit les intellectuels
ne savent pas quoi dire tout mais un peu
interloqué ouh là là mais tout à coup
ces gens votent tout à coup c'est jean
des préoccupations ont des soucis ont
des angoisses sont des demandes ce qui
s'est passé en fait
et voyez quand vous disais tout à
l'heure valérie pécresse chasse sur les
plates bandes du front national je
comprends que vous disiez ça parce que
c'est vrai que ça veut dire à quelque
chose de vulgaire qu'elles sont en grève
le pen l'avait dit avant elle
oui en 2016 mais ce qu'il ya c'est que
par justement parce que précisément le
souci des hommes politiques maintenant
et de ne pas être considéré comme
chassant sur les placements du front
national il ne voit plus les problèmes
de ces classes populaires et moyennes
ce qui se passe en france je l' ai déjà
dit sur ce plateau se passe dans tous
les autres pays de l'europe de l'union
européenne et les etats unis
on sait parfaitement ce qui se passe
parce que là ils sont peut-être à 32%
avec debout la france et 24% mais il
était surtout très peu en retrait de 2%
il ya 20 ans ils ont n'ont cessé de
progresser
alors on sait très bien ce qui se passe
soit ils arrivent au pouvoir
soit il ya une coalition coalition
gouvernementale on est obligé de les
mettre au gouvernement tellement
représente de gens soient troisième
solution et on espère que c'est ça qui
va arriver
partis du gouvernement commencent à
regarder les problèmes de ces classes
populaires et moyennes
et à vouloir y apporter des solutions je
rappelle qu'en suède
les démocrates le parti démocrate de
suède devait faire 25 26 % aux dernières
législatives selon les sondages ils
n'ont fait entre guillemets que 19 %
précisément parce que le pasteur
gouvernement avait commencé à répondre
aux préoccupations de ses classes
populaires alors on regarde un peu ce
que les internautes nous dit sur le
sujet d'abord sur la question que l'on
pose et sont ils une aubaine pelé gilet
jaune sont ils une aubaine politique
pour le restant de ma nationale vous
êtes 58% une majorité donc assez net
estimé que oui pas tu nous dis leur
assemblée nationale monte avant les
gilet jaune il vous elle vous rejoins où
il je ne sais pas caroline pour anti le
rn fait beaucoup de démagogie donc
forcément ça marche bien dans les
moments de confusion et citoyens nous
dit le meilleur acteur de la montée du
rassemblant nationale porte un nom c'est
l'exécutif un jeu dire une petite chose
marie amélie c'est que réagir à ce que
vous disiez sur le fait que
traditionnellement le front national
avait de très bons résultats aux
élections européennes traditionnellement
il a eu des élus parce que c'est un
scrutin proportionnel mais c'est pas
traditionnels qui les deux très bons
résultats je rappelle qu'en 2009 je
rappelle mais il avait des élus mais je
rappelle que en 2009 c'est europe
écologie les verts qui a eu un bon
résultat au niveau du ps qui faisait
encore 16 donc on est dans quelque chose
qui s'est profondément reconfigurer en
disant ils ont été premiers en 2014 mais
c'est une évolution récente et là ce
qu'on voit ça fait dix ans donc ce qu'on
voit c'est que l'on pensait qu'ils
étaient effectivement dans une situation
difficile et il retrouve du poil de la
bête mais c'est quelque chose qui est
profondément fluctuant de la même
manière qu'en italie la question de la
ligue ou du mouvement 5 étoiles le
mouvement 5 étoiles c'est en disant
qu'il est devenu le mouvement dominant
en italie donc on est dans une période
d'extrême mouvance et je veux dire par
là qu'on est très pessimiste lorsqu'on
parle parce que je pense qu'on est tous
enfin moi personnellement je suis très
anti rassemblement national et je pense
que cette espèce de reconfiguration
parce que cette espèce de cette espèce
de reconfiguration permanence est une
espèce de mouvement qui peut aussi
donner lieu à des dynamiques positives
par rapport à ce que vous disiez sur la
suette je termine juste l'afd par
exemple a fait de beaucoup moins bons
résultats
extrême droite almohades en allemagne
que ce n'était prévu aux élections
régionales donc on est dans une
situation où en fait y aller sans la
dir-ce s'émouvant il ya des cycles et ça
veut dire que dans certains pays au
contraire l'extrême droite est plutôt en
baisse marque un dernier point un
sondage paru lundi qu à peu été
commentée et qui faisait l'hypothèse de
la constitution d'une liste gilet jaune
et les résultats n'étaient pas du tout
les mêmes et on voyait que le parti qui
perdait le plus était le rassemblement
national
parce que finalement pompe est alors
temps que c'est la séparation s'est
faite par ipsos et qui commande
non mais ça donne ça peu de
renseignements aussi c'est le fait est
là pour résister lesquels résultat ça
donnait pour une liste chez les jaunes
c'était quoi c'était une dizaine de
points 12 sur la fluctuation de tous les
rêves il ya quelque chose aussi de
l'utilisation des partis de gouvernement
du front national comme l'opposition
voulu parce que c'est moi ou le chaos
or on voit bien que ça ne marche plus
comme ça c'est à dire que le monde
moderne un des derniers articles c'était
sur une belle macro et est censé être le
barrage à marine le pen c'est
l'autoroute et on voit bien que face à
ce mouvement dès il est jeune il a peu
de réponses et c'est pas les réponses
dans l'urgence avec les amis du cac 40
pour donner quelques minutes avant noël
qui vont enlever c'est vrai tu m'as
compris mr mentionner tous les ans tout
en tout les onze jeudi qu'il a joué le
même juge tout le monde et il faut pas
s'étonner si le front national on bosse
autant la fille je pense fait justement
est un des rares partis populaires
essayer d'aller voir sur plusieurs
niveaux dans l'autoroute et c'est pour
ça oui mais juste on ne peut pas être
irriguera sioniste et vouloir protéger
prétend de protéger ses classes
populaires et moyennes
et d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve c'est
qu'il est tout ce débat sur le pacte de
l'onu et les préoccupations qui ont été
des cg les jeunes par rapport à ce pack
sur l'immigration donc ces sujets suivez
bien on avale en parle de trop puisque
formidable alors effectivement le thème
n'est pas sans lien l'elysée annoncé
hier que parmi les cinq sujets qui sont
retenus pour ce grand débat local qui
devraient souffrir incessamment